the White House's proposed immigration
deal gives a major concession to
Democrats amnesty a pathway to
citizenship not simply for daca
beneficiaries but for about a million
other people and maybe more but instead
of being happy about getting what they
asked for Democrats as a group are
rejecting an out of hand they claim the
deal demands increased border security
and less unskilled immigration and
that's an effort to hold dreamers
hostage and is itself a form of white
supremacy the ranking Democrat in the
House of Representatives Nancy Pelosi of
San Francisco went on the floor recently
to call this in effect racism is it
Henry Fernandez is a fellow at the
Center for American Progress and joins
us tonight mr. Fernandez thanks for
coming on absolutely it's good to be
here Tucker so we talk about immigration
a lot with guests but you're a little
different because I think you take the
subject very seriously you think about
it you have for a long time you know you
sort know what the numbers are and I'm
not paying you false compliments I'm
serious I want to ask you an overview
question because I think you can handle
it you probably thought about so the
year I was born 1969 the United States
had 202 million people living in this
country 2015 the population had gone to
324 million that's more than 60%
increase three years later was even
higher than that 2065 it's expected to
be at 441 million that's a hundred and
eighteen percent increase now all of
that pretty much is due to immigration
and my question to you is what's the
right number how many people immigration
shapes the number of people who are here
it drives it how many people should live
in this country that's art that's a
really interesting question I haven't
spent a lot of time thinking through
that but you know I I feel like it's
certainly one worth discussing and and
trying to figure out what our policy
should be with regard to growth perfect
isn't that kind of this isn't that kind
of the central question
I mean population defines everything in
a country but by the way the cost of
infrastructure and schools and medical
care all of that is connected directly
to population and it just changes the
country completely why haven't you
thought about that well I guess what I'm
interested in right now
is a much smaller group of people just a
kind of very narrow issue which is these
dreamers and making sure that they have
a pathway to citizenship here in the US
so that's really been my focus I haven't
thought you clearly think in really big
ways and I try just because because it's
completely changed the country that I
grew up in in some ways for better I
think and in some ways for better maybe
I mean you could you could debate it in
some ways definitely for worse crowding
is bad right Beijing is a disaster Puget
Sound is beautiful I mean population is
related to that so density matters so
here's my question if you're for the
dreamers then you must be pretty happy
with this this proposal from the White
House which gives them amnesty why
should and we were led to believe that
all the left wanted was amnesty for
these people who are brought here as
children against the will and I kind of
got that but now Democrats are saying
all of their relatives have to come here
to and get public services so like how
how does that work I don't think
anybody's actually arguing for all their
relatives or for public services look
there's actually an interesting bill
that's out there right now very
bipartisan from congressman Hurd
Republican congressman a gr Democrat
that has 52 co-sponsors 26 Democrats 26
Republicans in the house and it does
exactly what we need to do right now
which is focus on dream and making sure
dreamers have have a pathway to
citizenship and border security that
seems like a fair trade and what the
Trump administration has tried to do
really driven by Stephen Miller who
seems to be the puppet master on this is
to try to throw in the kitchen sink here
every kind of trying to get control
that's that's extremist I mean spare me
let me ask you a serious question though
so I hear from a lot of people I think
including you that it's in America's
economic interest to let these people in
and they're largely from Mexico not
entirely but the majority are from
Mexico so if that's true if a lot of
low-wage labor
makes a country rich then why isn't
Mexico rich I guess are we talking about
the dreamers or are you not simply
talking specifically about the dreamers
but you could apply the same question to
about a million people we admit every
year for the sake of giving employers
lower wages why aren't the countries
from which they're coming rich if
low-wage labor is the key to prosperity
well I don't know you know about your
family but let's look at most American
families and and how they got here
through immigration which is that people
come to the United States because of
what it says on the Statue of Liberty
right that they're coming because they
are coming for Economic Opportunity
they're coming because they're fleeing
despotism this is how the Irish wound up
here this is how the Italians how the
Chinese sorry I'm a really simple
question about the people who live here
now and a lot of them are from other
countries are a lot of really decent
immigrants who live here in our citizens
how are they how are all of us going to
benefit economically from continued low
wage immigration I'm not asking whether
it's morally great to let people and of
course it is I'm asking about the
economic benefit and I never get an
answer for that
because you know the reason one well no
actually I mean if we look at
immigration it's pretty consistently
agreed upon by virtually all economists
that immigration significantly benefits
the US economy if we take just one issue
that's a lot you shouldn't say that
because it's not no it's not true that's
actually let's just take let's take one
issue right should give it to me
questions I'm sorry okay just the Social
Security trust fund it relies heavily on
immigrants to subsidize the large number
of people who are retiring now so
actually it's not a lie and I would
never lie to you Tucker that's not what
I do okay Henry thank you for coming on
I appreciate it of course good the beard
sucker